So copernicium, or copernicium as the discoverers
would
prefer it to be pronounced, is the latest
name to go up on the
periodic table and it is really very exciting
because it is the
first time in as many years that a new name
has appeared.
And not only has it appeared but quite excitingly,
it has
appeared with a bit of controversy - what
should the symbol
be? The first suggestion was that it should
be called, the
symbol should be Cp, capital C with little
p and that has got
really quite an argument inorganic chemists
who use organic
groups in their compounds got quite excited
because Cp is
the symbol that is used for cyclopentadienyl
ion which binds
to all sorts of different metals and then
it was discovered or
realised that, many, many years ago, Cp was
used as an
alternative symbol for element number 71,
lutetium, which in
some countries we called cassiopeium. And
I’ve looked in lots
and lots of books that I have got at home
and I can’t find one
of them that uses this name, but the reason
why it is
important is because now more and more old
papers, old
books are being digitised on the internet,
if you start
searching for the symbol Cp it will start
throwing up old
papers and cause confusion. So the decision
has been made
by the International Union of Pure and Applied
Chemistry or
the recommendation is that the symbol should
be Cn, capital
C, little n. And I think that this is a very
sensible suggestion
because it is unlikely that it can be confused
with cyanide
which is capital C, capital N. And it is also
nice for our Chinese
colleagues because Cn is the domain name for
Chinese
websites and I think most chemists will be
very happy with
that.
The element itself was first made quite a
few years ago, and
it’s made like all these heavy elements
by taking the nuclei of
two atoms that are lighter and banging them
together and if
you are aiming for element 112 then you need
to take 2
nuclei, which have atomic numbers which when
you add them
together come up to 112, so in this case you
take lead which
is atomic number 82 and so to get from 82
to 112 you need
to add 30, so you accelerate zinc atoms which
have atomic
number of 30 towards these in a high speed
accelerator and
every so often, and quite rarely, these two
nuclei fuse
together to give you an element or an atom
of element 112.
When you make the atom, it exists, for a short
time which
might be a thousandth of a second, or a few
thousandths of a
second or it might be as long as half a second
or even a
second. And then the nucleus of the atom starts
to decay.
Now it doesn’t blow into parts which are
just protons and
neutrons in one great whoosh! But instead
it starts going
down by steps, usually the atomic number changes
by two
units or one unit depending what sort of particle
is ejected
from the nucleus. So in the case of 112, and
I don’t know the
details yet, it will decay. For example, the
first step may be
going from 112 to 110 then the second step
may be just one
unit to 109, and then two down to 107 and
so on. Until you
get to an element below the mass of uranium
the mass of 92
- which is stable.